after the huge success of the first
season of daredevil on Netflix Marvel
continues to expand its universe on the
small screen with Jessica Jones based on
the character created by comic book
writer Brian Michael Bendis and artist
Michael Gaydos like its predecessor
Jessica Jones features 13 episodes for
about 50 minutes each the first episode
dives straight into the current day
story of superhero turned private
investigator Jessica Jones subsequent
episodes maintain an air of mystery as
they steadily reveal aspects of her
character building Jessica's world in
the present day while gradually
uncovering her tortured past via
traumatic visions and just as Marvel
approached daredevil as a crime drama
first in a superhero show second jessica
jones puts the focus on film noir and
psychological drama so expect many of
the usual moi trappings including a
cynical private detective voice-over
narration hard-boiled repartee
flashbacks and shadows cast by venetian
blinds if you enjoyed the grounded
grittiness and relative realism of
daredevil there's a lot for you to look
forward to in this new series which
again is set in Hell's Kitchen New York
and if you're into Easter eggs there's
plenty to keep your eyes and ears open
for - and I'll have a video on just that
once the full series is released this
week on Netflix oh and the show also
cleverly gears up for Marvel's next big
screen outing in 2016 Captain America
Civil War Breaking Bad's Kristen Rissa
is flat-out phenomenal in the lead
bringing the whiskey guzzling
tough-talking sarcasm spouting Jessica
to vivid life Reese is equally good at
spitting out darkly comic comebacks and
snubbing social niceties as she isn't
unveiling Jessica's disturbing demons
and delivering powerful punches as Luke
Cage actor Mike Colter shares great
chemistry with Ritter expect some pretty
intense scenes that are about as far
away as you can get from the pg-13
hookup that never was between the Hulk
and Black Widow and after seeing Colter
as caged in this series I'm looking
forward to his own Luke Cage series next
year like Daredevils Wilson Fisk David
Tennant's mind-controlling psycho
kilgrave's slowly but surely emerges
from the shadows as one hell of a creepy
villain Rachel Taylor
puts in a nicely understated turn as
Jessica's estranged best friend Trish
Walker who's a radio show host and
former child star as NYPD cop will
Simpson actor will travel provides solid
support and I can't shake the feeling
that travel has something of Chris Evans
is Captain America about him and carry
on Marcy's probably still best known as
Trinity in the Matrix movies puts in a
great turn as a cold and calculating
lawyer jeryn hogarth action wise from
the first seven episodes that I've seen
Jessica Jones isn't as visceral or
striking as daredevil though when there
is action it is well-executed
and just as daredevil doesn't flinch and
showing the brutal side of Matt Murdock
story Jessica Jones certainly doesn't
shy away from mature themes including
psychological and physical abuse and
blame and shame yet despite this dark
and serious side to Jessica Jones there
is a lot of humor in the series much of
it and surprisingly thanks to the show's
lead so although this series didn't grab
me quite as immediately as daredevil did
Jessica Jones is a show that grew on me
the more I watched it and I'm certainly
looking forward to seeing the final six
episodes so to sum up Marvel's Jessica
Jones is a more intense series that
matches great writing from showrunner
Melissa Rosenberg with a superb cast led
by a pitch-perfect performance from
Kristen Rissa Jessica Jones gets 4 out
of 5 flicks so guys are you looking
forward to Jessica Jones and if you've
seen it what did you think were you a
fan of Marvel's daredevil and what would
you like to see in the season 2 of that
series let me know in the comments below
once i've watched the final six episodes
of jessica jones I'll be making a
spoiler rific easter egg video for the
whole season
and I'll add an annotation here as soon
as it's live and as always do please
like share and comment and hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this thanks for watching and see you
next time you be guy a superhero lovers
you